all right well thanks very much for that
introduction um thanks very much to uh
everyone at pi data for giving the
opportunity to speak here today um it's
been a pretty great conference so far
and i thought my talk might be a little
bit uh weird and out of the ordinary
although i feel like all the attacks
have been pretty eclectic so maybe i
won't stand out as much but
today basically i'm i'm here to champion
a piece of software called avo plot
and avalo plot is a tool being developed
by our research group at the university
of cambridge
and it aims to make scientific data
visualization easier particularly for
those people who are less computer
literate less
coding capable but also we hope that it
will be a tool that can be used by the
avid programmer as well
it's written entirely in python and it
makes use of the very excellent
matplotlib plotting library which is why
we like to think of it as life after
matplotlib
because we love matplotlib and
our aim here is not to reinvent the
wheel not to make a new plotting library
but rather to use the tools that are
there
to let people do more with it and make
it easier for people to use it even
people who like i said can't code or
can't go very well
so uh first off i'm going to start out
by kind of giving you an introduction to
to who i am and what i'm doing up here
talking to you today
so yeah before i talk about the software
i'll introduce myself and my team
uh to give you an idea of where we're
coming from
because ultimately the software has come
from that same place so it gives you a
bit of history so my research group is
known as the cambridge volcanology group
uh we're a group of phd students from
around the world studying volcanoes
around the world hence the gas mask
so yeah that's me behind the gas mask
and we're all using vastly different
techniques to study volcanoes in
different ways
gathering all sorts of data
and using those data data in different
ways and we all come from different
backgrounds both scientifically speaking
and
i.t speaking so
some people in our group have zero
computer programming skills and some
people
have very high computer programming
skills
personally i don't have a very strong
computer science background i will tell
you that right now and i will remind you
that throughout the talk that actually
this guy actually wrote 99.9 of the
program i'm going to talk to you about
today so of course if you have any
problems with it you can contact the
developer
um
about two years ago i started coding
python because of this guy nyle peters
before that my coding experience was
basically html and visual basic
so he taught me how to work with data in
a language like python which is very
good for doing math and science
but now i've been able to to help him a
little bit like i said the point one
percent of the code that wasn't by him
was by me um so i've grown a lot in that
two years
and uh i think that the fact that i'm
able to give this talk to you today sort
of embodies the idea of avo plot that is
someone who's not
an awesome computer programmer someone
who just has basic skills but knows what
they want to do and has a problem to
achieve and some data to work with
can essentially make their own computer
program that has a gui and is powered by
python and uses the very excellent
libraries that python already has to
offer
so yeah i guess the point is sort of if
i can do it anyone can that's my
message i also wanted to briefly mention
the software sustainability institute
who has a presence here today um so
there's two people sitting in the back
that if you have any questions about the
ssi you should speak with them
and i recommend that you check them out
they uh sponsored me in 2013 as a fellow
gave me an allowance of 3000 pounds to
travel to conferences and go to
workshops and things like that
and they can be a fantastic tool for
people who want to either publish
scientific
programs or
learn how to use different programs and
different tools and organize workshops
and things like that so i would
encourage you to do that if you're
interested
okay so now back to the story of apple
plot
so as i said my uh my team is a group of
volcanologists and and the avo plot
program really grew grew from the need
to solve real world problems so we like
to think that that's where we're coming
from is having real world problems and
and giving you an easy solution to work
with them
so avocad started in field work in chile
a couple years ago and this is
a picture of an erupting volcano called
pujawe cordon caye in southern chile
you probably haven't heard of it that's
because it's in the southern hemisphere
and no one really noticed up here but
it's kind of the equivalent of the
southern hemisphere equivalent of the
iceland eruption
so the ash from from this volcano made
its way into the stratosphere and
actually circumnavigated the entire
globe so that means it traveled all the
way around to the other side of the
earth canceled flights in new zealand
and then kept going and ended up back in
chile where it started so this was a
huge event
and while we were there we brought all
kinds of equipment so
here's some of the the devices that we
use which are
some everything from standard video
cameras
to spectrometers that look at the the
gases and the ash coming out of the
volcanic plume
in an attempt to measure how much stuff
is coming out of the volcano
so again we have all these different
it's called multi-parameter monitoring
where you have all these different tools
looking at the same thing at the same
time
and we had a
multitude of tools to help us do that
that were mostly written by postdocs and
phd students and staff years ago so we
had all this legacy code that didn't
work well together and to be honest none
of it really worked well at all
for example many of the of the tools we
were using you have to physically edit
the scripts in a text editor in the
field to do different parts of the
program that you want to run the
equipment
which is not easy in the field or with
gloves on and it's also not easy for
those of our group who had not done any
computer programming before so there was
a huge barrier for them
in addition there's there's a big need
for real-time data visualization so we
have data streaming into our computers
we want to be able to look at it right
away and see in the field real time and
maybe even do some small bits of
processing on that data to see what
we're actually looking at
and that can be very important on field
work when
very often as scientists our field work
is sort of a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity right so we're in the field
and we need to capture what's happening
in that moment
and for example
with the uh with the old scripts that we
used to use uh more often than not our
spectrometers would be pointed somewhere
not in the plume at all it would be
pointed out in space and so we would end
up with data that was nothing at all we
would spend an entire day in the field
and come back and realize oops we
actually didn't measure anything so
being able to look at your data as it's
coming in is really important
the other place where hablo plot was
heavily developed it was in a rather
chilly garage in antarctica so this is
uh
the lower erebus hut which is a
small science station about the size of
a garage on the side of an active
volcano in antarctica and this is where
much of the programming was done by that
guy with the big arrow nile
um
and i'll quote him here by saying
if you think that the code is messy then
think about how hard it is to type with
gloves on
so this is
so at arabis uh volcano uh we have a
large team there about
12 people are are at the base every
every year and everyone is doing
completely different things so
um
even more so than at that big volcano in
chile where we have people uh using
infrared cameras to look at the active
lava lake that's in the volcanic crater
we have people looking at the gas plume
uh we have people taking lidar data of
the ice caves that are on the ice around
the volcano we have all kinds of
different
studies happening there um so this is
where a lot of our custom tools
have happened and were developed it's
because we had all these needs that
arose and as a need for some new data
processing arose we thought hey we can
we can add this to avo plot we'll use
this this plotting program we have
which i'll eventually show you i promise
and we can add add this feature to work
with this specific data set
so the features have have largely been a
result of a direct need
um so avo plot started its life as a
tool for for visualizing gas data so the
stuff that we were doing here but
eventually um we found that we were
reusing bits of code from here and there
and that we were able to make more and
more tools and add on more and more
features
all right so so here we are with all
this data and bits of python code kind
of scattered about
and trying to work through it all
but eventually this would all build into
something greater which is avail plot
and this is our logo here
very nice avocado so that was basically
the brief history of the beginnings of
this project so a bunch of
volcanologists running around the world
at various volcanoes collecting data and
kind of trying to figure out what to do
with it and realizing that maybe it
could be better and then realizing maybe
other people could use this tool as well
so
next i'm going to talk a bit about
sort of the the more broad data handling
problems faced by scientists in general
um and i suppose it applies to
non-scientists as well handling data is
is a thing across many disciplines
and our examples come from personal
experience but like i said they're
widely applicable
and then we'll kind of combine that with
a look at what python tools are already
available and what we can do with those
tools
and then finally we'll talk about the
apple plot software itself uh what it
aims to achieve where we are in the
current design
and what we'd like to see in the future
and ideas for implementing new features
so
by its nature
science is data driven
um as such most of chemistry physics
biology geology
can be broken down into into a few key
steps
so firstly you collect a bunch of data
somewhere
often many different types of data for a
single project
and this this in particular is the
highly specialized step
so your data is always going to be very
specific and you might think that i i
need a really specialized tool to work
with this because
it's not easy as easy as just dumping it
in a spreadsheet
but then of course you import your data
into some kind of analysis software and
this
these are generally very these are often
very general tools like spreadsheets or
plain text data files csv files um but
again can be quite specialized like a
binary spectrum file for example
so then you want to do some processing
on your data
and as with the data import this can be
very general
um like fitting a line or a curve to
your data or again something very
specialized like fitting backgrounds or
modifying your your curve in some way
and finally you might iterate between
the processing and visualization steps
enough times until you get a product
that that looks the way you want it to
look either for publication or for
looking at the data in a visual way to
try to figure out what's going on
so okay so what's the problem then
so we need a general tool that can be
used for
specialized
data sets
that's pretty self-explanatory but the
second point i think is a bit is a bit
more subtle um
so there's no there's no point in having
to to repeat the work of specialization
uh each time you have to to process new
data
um
and there already may be tools used to
accomplish this so spreadsheets can be
used as templates to make
specializations reusable
and of course like i said we have a ton
of python tools to do this right
so you might say well python solves this
problem already so
so why are we even looking at this i
mean it's a general tool it can deal
with highly specialized cases
you can import general data like csv
using csv module
specialized cases can be handled using
custom written code for your particular
data set
and the same can be said for the
processing and visualization steps there
already exists these tools um
to to to work with the data and there's
of course many many more this is an
example of some of the modules that that
we use in our group
okay so if python already answers our
question then what's the real problem
here that we want to address um as i
mentioned before a lot of scientists are
not programmers um so although some will
happily write a script to achieve their
task others might find that completely
you know unapproachable um
so i'll give you one quick example
a member of our group named kelby who's
a brilliant guy
but not so brilliant when it comes to
i.t stuff
for example i once literally witnessed
him open a browser
and in the uh the search box which is a
google search he typed in yahoo
and then clicked the first result on
google which was yahoo.com and then in
the yahoo search box he typed yahoo mail
and then he clicked the first link and
that's how he got to his mail that's how
he got to his email was by
and i was just like watching horror as
this was happening
and this is a guy who was using all the
tools that we were in the field and
trying to work with these scripts and it
was just not something he had done
before and so there's a huge learning
curve for him right like he knew how to
how to work with the data on a more
uh general level but when it came to
okay how do i you know what what do i
type to get this to happen it was it was
just like it would have taken him 10
years to finish his phd because he had
to learn so much more just to catch up
to that
um so again like in our group we have
this huge range of people this guy niall
who wrote this software all the way down
to kelby who searches yahoo to get to
his email
the other thing about scientists is that
they're all they're typically in a hurry
time is short and so writing a specific
code that's going to have a really nice
interface isn't going to be reusable is
hard and we don't like to do it it's
easy to just quickly code something up
use it for what we need and then yeah
maybe save it and come back to it later
but
to be honest you know if you come back
to your code that you wrote two months
ago you're not going to have any idea
what it did unless you actually
documented it well um
and so yeah so scripting in addition can
be a frustrating way to visualize data
so like we do have this great tool
matplotlib uh and pi plot and you might
do you know piplot.plot your your data
finally you have this big script and
then you plot it and it looks beautiful
oh but uh i think i want to change the
color of those dots or the shape or i
want to
change the the axes or i want to change
the title you have to go back and rerun
your entire script uh to just to change
that one little thing and you might have
to iterate over that several times until
you get what you finally want so it's
just a it's a frustrating way to
approach a visual problem
with a scripting backend
so avoplot aims to sort of address these
questions in a few different ways
the first of which the first very
obvious thing is that it's essentially a
gui front end to matplotlib so it has
all the functionality of matplotlib
you can import
various types of data using text csv
files you can mainly manually type it in
and then you see your your plot in this
wonderful map window and you can change
the colors and the fonts and the styles
and everything so it just makes that
step easier
and in addition it has basic data
processing capabilities and this is
something that's definitely extensible
and we're trying to add tons more
features on this this end of things
but for example fitting a line is to
your data is one thing we can do we're
fitting a gaussian curve to something
things like that
and you can do that right within the
graphical interface which is nice
um
again like like i said you know moving
things around or changing your your plot
is just made easier in a drag and drop
interface i mean we love scripting of
course but sometimes you just want to
point and click
in addition apple plot is very easily
customizable so i'm going to talk in a
bit about plug-ins which is a huge part
of avo plot
and probably my favorite thing about it
basically it's a framework for
scientists to create their own
processing tools so someone even with
minimal
computer skills minimal coding skills
can create essentially their own
software program that has a gui and runs
with python in the background
so instead of very powerful tools
so here's basically the anatomy of of
our program and uh the three sort of
main points that we like to that we like
to think that we try to accomplish so
like i said the first thing is the gui
interface fantastic
um the second thing is plugins
like so like i was just mentioning
you can write a plugin for your specific
data type to import specific data from
whatever kind of file you have you can
work with it you can do all of the
processing either behind the scenes or
at the click of a button
and the third thing is i'm going to talk
about as well is our scripting interface
which is very new
but we hope to expand upon this
so
if you like to work in
mostly in a script interface rather than
a gui that's fine too and we think that
this
feature is going to be very good for
the more advanced programmers so you can
write a program instead of calling uh
piplot.plot you might call avap.plot and
then instead of opening your graph in a
matplotlib window it will open it in
apple plot so you can do your whole
script run everything just like you
normally would and just import avo plot
as a module
open up avo plot and then ruin your axes
and make your your graph look nice look
the way you want it to look
okay so i showed you i felt bad for
putting up so many slides filled with
text
so i wanted to have a quick uh story to
get your attention back
so so why is it called apple plot well
it's so named based on the ramblings of
someone who would actually eventually
become one of his end users
a guy called calvin barney who's another
member of our research group uh
he he's a big fan of things like
mathematica
which not to say mathematica isn't great
but he's a fan of this on the basis that
if it costs money it's better
and he decided to go on to a big rant on
a very hot day in the middle of the
ethiopian desert a few years ago and
explained to nyle the guy who wrote this
program why open source is bad and why
paying for programs is good
and so he was he this is paraphrasing
but to the best of our memory he said
something like
open source software is written by a
bunch of hippies living in a commune in
palo alto with their beards down to
their socks and sandals living on
nothing but organic avocados oh look at
me i'm so moral
so
in uh recognition of telvin's epic rant
on how much he hated open source
software and hated using linux and
hitting having to check the man pages
and write a wrapper for his usb driver
uh we named it after after that apple
plot
and like i said before this guy is now
actually using ammo plot so and he's
scripting in python now as well so we've
converted him i think
okay so finally a screenshot so this is
what apple plot looks like this is the
gui and i'll kind of take you through
take you through the screenshot a bit to
show you sort of the different sections
so we've broken it down into panels and
also tabs as well so you can open as
many panels as you like
well as many panels until the program
crashes but you know
in addition as many tabs as you like as
well
so you can look at for example
this is some data that that we look at
at volcanoes and we're looking at the
gases coming out of volcanoes and these
are the kind of data that are good to
see in real time
so this is a this is just running a
script that will pull data from a from a
folder will continually watch the folder
for new new files whenever a new file is
written it'll update these graphs and
then we can watch what's happening in
the volcano and be sure that our
instrument is actually pointed where we
want it to be pointed
um
so the current the current phase of
development is that it's very early
um but we have a stable release which is
available on google code um
and for the stable release we focus on
implementing a few number of fully
workable features rather than a bunch of
half-baked ideas although we have many
of those in the works too
for the back end we have ditched the map
outlet back-end and we actually use wx
so you do have to have that installed
and
okay so yeah
um
so when you're writing when you're
writing uh if you're writing a plugin
for example for for avo plot
you you work in like i said you have
these panels and um
so the
the navigation panel you can select
either which which window you're looking
at or which tab or which you can plot
multiple lines for example in a single
graph so you could select which line
and then the control panel will change
depending on which thing you've selected
in the navigation panel so if you've
selected a particular line you might
have tools to
to
our particular data set you might have
tools to fit a curve or to change the
color of the line
or to perform
math and processing on that data
if you've selected the the whole subplot
then you'll have these control panel
tools where you can change like the the
axes and the title and the um the color
of the plot window and things like that
oh and notice that all of the matplotlib
tools are readily available so
like the ones you know and love the zoom
and pan and home and all that are just
right there on the top
okay and then something i mentioned
before that we're really excited about
is this brand new scripting interface
which we just released with the the
latest release
um
and
so as well as this basic gui um
you can you can work with avoplot uh
from a scripting interface um and
although only a few commands are
currently um
implemented but we hope to to grow it
and also one thing we're hoping to to
achieve here is maybe get get more of
you developing on it as well which would
be fantastic
so it's basically designed to mimic
the pi plot interface um making it
really simple for people who already use
matplotlib to just like i said import
avo plot and plot and then it opens your
plot in in our program instead
um
and so that if you have existing scripts
for example they can already be changed
very easily
uh plugins which i think is is what
makes this really powerful um and very
very usable for people who maybe aren't
as avid as coders but maybe just
starting out
is uh is is the fact that it's a plug-in
interface
so the most simple the most simple
plug-in
like just a few lines of code um
will allow unsupported data files uh to
be loaded like
by a point and click of like file new
um but more complex ones allow you to
find define your own access specific
data series types
specific data processing tools you know
adding buttons and things like that
plugins are distributed using disk g
tills
and a bunch of so so loads of loads of
scripts like quick and dirty scripts are
written by scientists every day right
but we'd like to offer avo plot as sort
of a framework for them to build better
reusable code that can then also be used
by others and in addition you get this
gui interface um so a lot of the hard
work so like i said writing writing good
reusable programs with that look really
nice is hard and it takes a lot of time
um but if with avo plot we'd like to
think that we've sort of set up
the the framework for you
so all the things are there and you kind
of plug and play
uh i mean it can be very very very
simple or very complex but you can
basically just plug and play your
specific data types and name your axes
and things like that and then if you
have
tons of data that you want to work with
run your your plug-in on on all of these
data and
in fact then hopefully other people in
your field can use that as well
so the thing about the thing about the
plug-ins i think is is really important
is the fact that
it's it's less like a traditional
plug-in interface where maybe you've
written a plug-in and you've added some
kind of functionality to the main
program
instead really uh the plugins work from
the very very top level
so file new you choose right from the
file new menu which plugin you're using
to open a file
and so it the the plugin will will
interact with the data that you import
right away from the very top level and
it will always give you the commands
specific to that plug-in which are
specific to your data type
and so really a plug-in is like
writing your own program that just sits
on top of avo plot so you can write
what's essentially its own software
program and very easily with uh with a
nice gui and very powerful tools behind
it
so despite being at such an early stage
of development still
avo plot is is currently being used by
our group
this is the guy who searches yahoo for
his mail and he's um
he's doing a a walking traverse using a
spectrometer that's on the back of his
helmet so he's walking on the rim of a
volcano measuring
the gases that are above his head
so he's actually up here this is the
eureka volcano in chile
and then our the other half of our team
would be on the ground a couple
kilometers away from the volcano at the
same time
with these instruments pointed at the
same stuff so again we have this
multi-parameter approach where we have
tons of different instruments looking um
at the same thing
and um
so like i said our our first version of
apple plotter what would become avo plot
was a tool
for this specific kind of data
and
the speed and ease of making making
plots has has shown us really that's
been a really
very very usable uh useful tool for
sorting through the the gigabytes of
multi-instrument data that we have
and to identify specific periods of time
that are interesting
um so one one more quick example of what
a plug-in can be
is one that i wrote myself
so again i want to sort of champion the
fact that i'm a novice coder and yet i
was able to write a plugin that's
essentially my own computer program
um that's been a very powerful tool for
me in my research
so the data that i that i use often look
like this the the dark blue line
and uh what i need to be able to do is
fit background curves
beneath the data to subtract out um a
background from to get the real data
subtract out the noise
and the way this is traditionally done
by people in my field believe it or not
is by printing these out on paper and
drawing curves with a pen or pencil and
then measuring them with a ruler and
that sucks when you have hundreds of
these things
um and in fact my
my my
sort of inspiration to write this thing
because i was afraid of you know i could
do a little bit of python use ipython do
some math and stuff great um but i was
afraid to say i couldn't you know i
can't write a program i don't know what
i'm doing and niall the guy who who
wrote avoplot caught me um printing out
a bunch of these things he's like what
are you doing and i was like well that's
just how it's done you know and he's
like no no no we we can make this better
so um
this is i was able to use his examples
that he has up um on the google code
page
and um basically build my own program
from scratch and now i've used that
throughout my phd
so quickly a few thoughts about the
future of apple plot and really bringing
home the idea of
why
we think data visualization can be made
better um
even with the existing tools that are
already there which are great so this is
uh to one set of data but on the left is
the same as what's plotted here
and if i asked you to
pick out the anomalous point
uh i think you might choose to look at
the the plot here
i think if if i gave you this set of
data you wouldn't know which one was
which but when you look at it in a
visual space you can say okay it's right
there this is the point that we need
um
and i think that that kind of it's a
simple example of course but it sort of
embodies the idea behind apple plot
which is uh so much of our data is in
numbers space it's in spreadsheets um
which is has been traditionally great
for working with all different kinds of
data it's versatile in general but
if
looking at our data in a visual way can
be so much more powerful why are we
always stuck in this numbers space
so we're hope we're hopeful that that
this library of plugins that we're
slowly building are going to be able to
help people and that the people will
help develop on it and make their own
specialized tools and then eventually
we'll uh
we'll have a really uh powerful
extensive database
okay so
the program works sort of it's an early
it's an early release but it's a stable
release um and we like to think that
it's useful but we're we're desperately
in need of more developers so at the
moment it's basically nylon myself
and we don't have the time to to do all
the things that we would like to do with
the program so we would hope that people
would sign on
get information from our developer
developers list and maybe be able to use
it in their own research we would love
to see more people using it in different
ways that we never thought possible
and so um
technical questions can be sent to the
developer
and you can check out the program you
can download it now and start using it
or you can join the developers list
which is linked on the homepage of the
google code
and i will stop there and take any
questions that you may have